from your time with born on kcrw what
have you seen work in terms of the
essentials and storytelling you know
you've seen books that are shot to mega
stardom and you know been on the New
York Times bestseller list what are some
of the essential elements that you've
seen from the books that have really
taken the public by storm you know
bookworm Michael silverblatt only talks
with writers of literary fiction and
poetry he doesn't do shaumbra the show
doesn't do noir it doesn't do thrillers
it doesn't do detective stories it only
does literary fiction and ultimate
literary literary fiction doesn't care
about the audience it's again it is
built and if the audience comes great I
have been more involved with the
essentials of storytelling from from the
movies from movies the movies that I
admire and a lot of what I've liked
about storytelling in movies has has
vanished it's really not in the movies
so much anymore the well-constructed
story i think is to some degree a thing
of the past can you give examples of
films that follow that and then also
maybe mainstream box office hits
nowadays that are still good but leave
that behind
well let's talk about zero dark thirty
Kathryn Bigelow's brilliant movie what
is the story of zero dark thirty is the
story of this woman who helps us catch
Osama bin Laden and kill him or this
woman who loses her way and winds up
crying and alone at the end of the movie
what is the story there it's not you
know this could have been a Betty Davis
movie in the 30s and it would have been
very different in the terms of
storytelling
silver linings play book is pretty
traditionally a story movie but it
begins very seriously with two people in
very serious trouble and then it turns
into a charming romantic comedy dance
film it changes genre before our eyes
and the audience chews it up I do think
traditional storytelling is that we've
we've we've kind of moved past it as a
species I mean a lot of popular just
popular fiction popular movies are very
very traditional like the romantic film
trying to think of the Casa Betty's film
not John the Father the Son the notebook
for example the notebook is very
traditional and there there's a place
for that but in terms of what the movies
really are where they're really going I
don't think it's there do you think just
because we've sped up as a society that
things are so instantaneous that we've
moved beyond that or do you think we'll
return to that traditional storytelling
room
I have no idea I I know that in my own
family that my great nieces and
great-nephews are familiar with concepts
that I didn't get to until I was in my
40s I mean they they talk about
boundaries they talk about dysfunction
their concepts in in us that we do
evolve and I think a certain way of you
know storytelling is the most ancient
human accomplishment storytelling so
it's just storytelling will always be
here but it's a how a story is told and
what is considered your story changes
you